foreign
Bonnie
Bonnie oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I was born in Boston
or just outside of Boston but grew up in
Upstate New York
tell me about your family growing up uh
my dad was heroin addicts an artist
Mom very young mom that ran away from
home at 19 to be with my dad
my dad started
sexually abusing me when I was two or
three years old
um
mom knew about it kind of
I would tell anybody that wanted to hear
me even at that age if it was Sunday
school or if it was a babysitter or
anyone I would tell them I didn't like
my dad touching me
I would tell my mom same thing you know
and
she just shake her head and
police would come to the house and my
mom would hide them we had kind of like
a hidden hallway in our apartment at the
time she would hide my dad from the
police or the social services the
workers that came
um
shortly thereafter my mom started making
me take baths with little girls that
lived in the apartment building and my
dad would watch
uh things like that continued
for years and years back and forth from
Boston to Rochester New York her family
would come pick her up
bring her back my dad would call and
she'd go right back and it continued
like that until I was seven years old
it sounds like your mom was almost like
feeding his
yeah yeah ended up having a really major
surgery when I was five years old
because some of the sexual abuse was so
bad that it damaged my bladder and my
urethra and um
had major surgery at age five
by seven you know other kids had come
along my mom had three of us now
and she finally moved back to her family
in Upstate New York and um
at seven years old I was outside playing
and uh
man across the street asked me to
babysit and I went over because of
course I wanted to be a big girl at age
seven and I
went over to babysit and he brought me
upstairs into an attic and um
proceeded to touch me and
um
instantly I thought this man's doing the
same thing that Daddy did
so I knew
how to react I was frozen I was calm
um he threw me around slapped me
threatened me told me if I told anyone
that he would kill my family
he bribed me if I shut my mouth I'd have
a beautiful room like his daughter
um
we didn't have much of anything
and I knew enough to survive so
I was quiet and I waited while he did
some things to me and the first second
the first chance I had
I ran down the attic stairs across the
street and screamed to my mom you know
this man he did what Daddy did to me
and she called her brothers they beat
the [__] out of them put him in the
hospital for months
had to do a whole court trial rape kit
as a child that was very traumatic
and never heard what happened to him
after that
if he was convicted I I in my
recollection I just remember being on
the stand as a child and having to
recount that it was so hard
and it was it was just so hard
but I did it and
when I was eight years old
my mom met her
now current husband
he also started sexually and physically
abusing myself and my sister
um the physical abuse was to my brother
but most of the sexual things were my
sister and I
um
it was pretty bad some pretty intense
graphic stuff
um
as little girls pulling us on top of him
to perform
oral sex on us or to
make us
touch him until he
you know climaxed and
just really graphic stuff I went through
with him
um
we're too afraid to say anything because
he literally beat the [__] out of us he
would hit us with
I remember this big leather belt that
had metal studs
and he would Hold Us by one arm he was
big like six foot five and just whale on
us with that belt
he beat my brother so hard one time he
lost control of his bladder
and I was the oldest so I always felt I
had to protect them and that was
probably the worst part for me watching
my brothers and sisters endure that
um
my sister became a chronic bedwetter
we'd do anything to try to hide it
because of course that meant he would
hit us whether it was he had two by
fours he would beat us with anything he
would take us by the back of our hair
and rub our face in the pissy mattress
and
he was just evil
um
we weren't allowed to touch food
in the refrigerator we're always hungry
always hungry he started urinating in
soda cans and putting them in the
refrigerator so that as kids who would
run in and grab a drink from the fridge
they were drinking urine
um
I was tough
to this day
she's still married to him my mom was
fully aware that all this was happening
I mean how could she not be
if you you know traditional kid I will
not swear you know I will not swear he'd
give you a composition book to fill
every line had to be filled
take the piece of paper hold it up
against a door and stand there with your
nose and hold that piece of paper and
don't let that paper hit the floor
don't let that paper Hit the Floor we
would stand there so long our legs would
buckle
it was just a really
cruel cruel punishments that he
inflicted on us our entire life
finally when I was in high school
I made a varsity cheerleading team and I
was so proud of myself
I came home from practice really late
and
if on my sister locked in her room
crying and
my stepdad had done some really rotten
things to her when I was gone uh
kind of graphic involving like studded
leather collars and like just some
really like
left field [__] that no kid should see
and
he also
did some things to her that night that
uh
scared her so bad she would not come out
of her room and I decided that
I'd had it
I was going to have to quit something
that I loved again which was the cheer
sport
or else I was gonna die
and I had tried several times to take my
life at that point
taking pills
cutting myself
never got any therapy throughout any of
this [__] which is crazy to me you've
never done therapy never never
done therapy I've never
sold my body I've never done hard drugs
I
have tried
to deal with all of this on my own I'm
going to be 52 this year and I'm
starting to realize that I'm pretty
[__] up I feel like I'm starting to
really unravel and you know very good at
making everything look put together when
I have to
therapy would probably
be Yes actually Monday I have my first
therapy appointment with my sister so
yeah that's great yeah yep
um
don't remember where we left off just
unload everything you can
okay so that's where we're 17. with your
with your sister on Monday oh yeah just
my advice is just to unload everything
unload everything okay
yeah if you want to get past it I do I
do I really do and I think that's why
I'm here too it's part of my healing
Journey if I can even help one person to
say hey you know what there's another
day there's tomorrow don't hurt yourself
don't do anything crazy but you can
survive you can survive yeah we're
broken we're not perfect but who the
hell is right
who is I'm a work in progress
how did your childhood impact your adult
life oh huge well when I was 17 I told
you I had enough and um instead of
killing myself I decided I'm gonna sit
my mom down and she's gonna face some
real facts I talked to her and told her
everything that her husband had been
doing sexually she knew about the
physical beatings but he always waited
until she wasn't around to do the sexual
stuff
we had a whole thing set up with a
camera and we had a tape recorder and
she was gonna act like she was leaving
and come in and you know no that didn't
happen as soon as he came in the door
from work
please come in the bedroom we need to
talk she brought him in the bedroom told
him everything and of course you know us
girls were lying and blah blah blah
she um didn't leave she didn't care but
one good thing that came out of it is
the physical
the physical abuse slowed down at the
sexual abuse with him stopped
a few months later that year
I got pregnant at 17 years old and they
threw me out of the house pregnant
and I had to sleep in a car in an apple
orchard
across the street from my house for a
long time wouldn't have anywhere to go
that was rough ended up being a very
high risk pregnancy because of the
kidney problems that I had when I was a
child
um
had a daughter at 18 years old
had a divorce by the time I was 21.
screwed up my whole entire life I really
made some bad decisions
I I was used to sell drugs I
was promiscuous
um grew up in a rough neighborhood you
know grew up in what people called
projects or the hood like really drugs
huh there's always drugs exactly and
here I am single mom with an 18 year old
with a baby with no parents no support
no nothing no one
it was so hard I made choices out of
desperation I was easy to manipulate it
was great that you stayed away from
drugs your drug use yourself well
I like the flower but other than that
nothing I never did heavy stuff or
I think when I look at some people that
I've grown up with and some of the
things they've been through they've
taken quite a different path
I think probably moving
down south here changed my life got me
out of that environment away from a lot
of that a lot of those people although
um
it was forceful you know I don't know
how much I can actually talk about but
um
eventually we were caught I was caught
selling drugs you know back and forth
across the country and um I was forced
to move down here
um
was rough but I think it really saved me
it changed my life I mean in my adult
life before that like I said selling
drugs I mean I had been
abused by many men physically of course
sexually I didn't realize boundaries or
respect for myself
I had to learn all that on my own the
hard way
I was jumped by five guys one night the
[__] beaten out of me broken nose
stitches across my legs I crawled under
a van to save my life literally
um
it's just a lot
it's a lot
did you have kids of your own no yeah I
have two daughters yeah I waited 10
years after I was 18 to have another
because it scared me and I always said
to myself you're such a [__] up broken
person you cannot be anyone's mom you no
one loves you you've never been loved
you don't know how to love you don't
know how to do all these things and here
I have this baby born to me which also I
believe saved my life
it's taught me unconditional love for
the first time in my life
and it made me want to be a better
person
but still in between I had to learn
those lessons the hard way like I said
running around with people with guns and
drugs all the time and
just trying to get money any way I could
to survive
yeah
Ben
dated a cop for a little while tried to
change my life around he ended up
beating the [__] out of me and was fired
held a gun to my head
um
it's made a lot of mistakes in my adult
life like I said as a result of it
I've had a lot of stress and when I was
probably in my late 20s
I had a
bleed in my brain which they say was
caused from
stress
thank God I had started working in the
hospital and I was had the hospital when
it happened I had a grandma seizure and
uh
stop breathing for 30 minutes
I had one of those weird near-death
experiences people talk about and um
I was going someplace really beautiful
but all I could think about were my
children all I could think about were my
girls
I just wanted to be with my girls I
wasn't ready then slowly kind of came
back into my body but it took me almost
a year after that to learn how to talk
again to use my left side
um
at the end of all this
I'm sitting here and uh
end-stage kidney disease
a lot of uh
what I've heard from the doctors is
because of the sexual abuse I suffered
as a kid
um
but I'm here
but I'm here you're a Survivor I am I'm
[__] up and I'm doing the best I can
and I still make mistakes but
you know I thought about doing this and
I said well who would I Inspire I'm
really no one who could I help you know
at my oldest daughter the firstborn
she's 33 now she has grandchild we have
grandchildren my grandson said to me
Grammy I don't know much about your life
but you are a great success you've made
us a beautiful family you're so kind and
you're here for us all the time and if
you can even help one person to know
that they can make it you should do it
and I just looked at him and I said wow
he's right
and so here I am no and I hope if I can
even
get through to one person let him know
that it's okay and it's not your fault
you're not dirty you don't have to be
embarrassed you you know for a long time
I grew up thinking like nobody's gonna
love me who wants to love somebody
that's been raped their whole life her
head that should be out of them that's
lived in hotels from DCF and
had to steal food to eat like I always
felt not good enough
always felt like that abandoned
like the child nobody wanted
you know but if I can even help one
person to know it's not their fault
they're not dirty they're not
to blame they're just a child
don't give up like keep going keep going
not that any of this was your fault but
are there do you have any regrets in
your life
well I certainly regret choices I made
when I was young you know um
used to fight a lot a lot
I used to fight a lot just walk up to
people and punch him in the face I
didn't like them because that's how I
was treated
I have a lot of regrets even as a child
you know I have a story where my stepdad
my sister was on his way home on her way
home from the store two kids jumped her
broke her milk took her bags came home
crying my stepdad looked at me and he
said go get him you go get him right now
sent me out of the house running like a
maniac I don't even know who I'm looking
for at this point come back home take my
sister with me we find the two little
kids and I just started beating the [__]
out of this kid and the next thing I
hear someone screaming it's their father
we take off he comes chasing us in a car
pins us against defense
pulls a gun out pulls it to our head I
had to be about
eight or nine years old at this point
pulls a gun out holds it to our head and
says uh you're the one hitting my son he
says to his son now you go fight her you
don't let a girl beat your ass you're
not a [__] you go fight her
made us fight in the park in Latin
then he says to the two little ones my
sister and his little brother you two
are going to fight too my sister who
never fought geez she was a little bit
more of the sensitive one just started
crying I remember just looking at her
crying and I had him like this and I
didn't even I just kept hitting him and
I wasn't even paying attention I wasn't
looking I was just worried about my
sister and the first chance we got I
told my sister run
we ran down the street got to our house
guy shows up pulls a gun out on my
stepdad
police are called his son comes running
up and I look down in his entire
face all of his clothes were covered in
blood
and I looked and I felt so bad this is
what I did to someone
this is what I did I was raised like a
[__] animal
and I felt terrible we had to go to
court
I wasn't allowed on his street he wasn't
allowed on my street for the rest of our
lives
but yeah so many stories like that where
we were just raised
to be bad people
and now when I raise my kids I just want
to be 100 everything that they're not
everything that they're not
what's your relationship like now with
your
with your mom we don't speak at all no
her three natural children none of us
speak to her or to her
husband who she's still with even after
everything
and it's hard
it's hard it's hard not having a mom ask
any anyone you know it's hard
always longing for that I don't know
anything about my dad
so I feel like you know other than my
kids and my husband
my brother and sister that's all I have
and it's hard
you know you wish you had someone to
call for advice or
even to know what you where you came
from why you look like this or why do
you talk like this I mean I I you know
it's hard
are you scared of doing therapy next
week
uh I guess I am I'm scared but I'm
optimistic I'm hopeful you know I think
it will help me I know it will help me
everybody that I've talked to that's
gone to therapy says that you know
they're so much better they wouldn't be
so
I'm optimistic yeah I'm scared there's a
lot of [__] to unpack you know and like
even now we're just kind of going you
know the tip of the iceberg but
it's a lot there's a lot of stuff to
unpack
I think that's why it's good that Monday
will be my first day because I may need
you know to debrief a little pit or you
know it's just hard it's hard to talk
about it opens up a lot of stuff that
like I said you think you're good and
you're doing great but then the next
thing you know you're 50 something years
old and you're like holy [__] I'm a mess
how did it make you feel as a child to
like know that these things were going
on that were wrong
and your mom like no no one did anything
about it nope I felt um alone
I felt very alone I felt unloved I felt
like I had nobody to protect me
I really just felt like nobody loved me
nobody wanted me nobody cared about
my well-being I didn't even have when I
tell you my mom was so bad she didn't
care if we had clothes she used to
encourage me to go to school
and steal sneakers from the locker room
or go to the store with her and take off
my shoes and put the new shoes on my
feet and walk out the store that's kind
of the way that she
raised us if you want to call it that
but yeah it's rough
and Bonnie what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned
in all of this
wow it's hard to pick one but I would
say
To Love Yourself give yourself some
Grace
um
you're not dirty it's not your fault
um you are worth it you are lovable
you can come onto this and be a strong
person a good person
I worked in a hospital for years taking
care of people and that was one of the
best things I've ever done I'm
definitely a caregiver and I've learned
to do exactly the opposite of what was
taught to me I mean I grew up with
the stepdad with Nazi tattoos on his
hands and you know always hearing things
about race
and stuff like that and it's
no surprise I completely
went away from everything they taught me
and my husband's a black man we've been
together for 28 years
so I feel like everything that they
instilled in me
like my cells just want to do opposite
with my kids
with my life period
period I used to paint I used to sculpt
I used to do photography like 34 years I
wasn't able to do anything like that
again I was so depressed I think and
just so messed up
finally let
maybe this last year or so I started
painting again and I sold one of my
paintings the first time in my life it
felt great and I for a long time
wondered like what is my purpose here
what am I here for just to be
a doormat you know but I realized no I'm
here to be a mom to be a wife and to to
do my art that's my passion
and if I can help anyone then even one
person Mark I would feel
like it was not all for nothing
I'm sure your talk will help someone I
hope so I hope so
I hope so
Bonnie thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you Mark I appreciate
it thank you lots of luck next week
thank you thank you